Ein solcher
Gammastrahlenausbruch könnte, das leben auf der erde nahezu komplett zerstört
Und es gibt thesen dass das schon einmal passiert ist hier auf unserem heimatplaneten genauer vor 440 millionen
jahren
Könnte es zum
Zweitgrößten artensterben geführt haben droht uns jetzt diese katastrophe wieder klicks und science fiction bei uns gibt es täglich wissenschafts videos aber
Und jeden kanal dann verpasst er keins mehr herzlich willkommen
Vielen dank für den themenvorschlag auf whatsapp
Wolfram jetzt sterne haben, alle eines gemeinsam es sind ehemalige große sterne die sehr massereich
Und kurzlebig sind und irgendwann einmal kollabieren bei dieser
Supernovaexplosion wird von beiden polen extrem mit gamma strahlung ausgesendet und die ist tödlich wenn
Ein bewohner planet in diesen strahlt gerät vor 440 millionen. Jahren könnte es bei der erde der fall gewesen sein
und um solch eine gammastrahlen bombe handelt es sich auch bei dem wolf riot stern namens wer
104 im sternbild schütze
Und astronomie teams sind sich einig wer 104 wird demnächst explodieren hinweise dazu liefert sein spektrum das auf eine starke
Instabilität schließen lässt konkret handelt es sich bei, wr 104. Um, ein doppelsternsystem zum. Einen aus einem ball. Frei jetzt stern
Ein, ehemaliger großer stern der seine atmosphäre ins all geblasen hat. Und von dem quasi nur. Noch der heiße kern
Übrig ist er liegt im sternbild schütze. Und ist etwa 8000 lichtjahre von der erde entfernt bis
Zu 100 andere wolf reihen sterne die sich über die milchstraße verteilen sind uns bislang bekannt typischerweise
Stößt. So ein stern, ein extrem starken sternen wind aus der bis zu 2000 kilometer pro sekunde
Schnell sein kann, ein großer stern kann durch stern wind das mehrfache der erdmasse pro jahr verliert wahlfreiheit
Sterne sind sehr viel schwerer als die sonne sie können tatsächlich bis zum 200 fachen der sonnenmasse wiegen, ihre
Oberflächentemperatur ist zudem sehr. Heiß. Und zwar bis. Zu 100.000 kelvin im vergleich dazu sind die
5500 kelvin der sonne ja fast lächerlich zum anderen besteht das system aus einem sternen begleiter vom spektral
Der deutlich weniger, masse hat der extrem starke wind der vom wall freiheit stern abgeht
Tritt auf dem wind seines begleiters so dass eine stoßwelle entsteht der sternen wind verdichtet
Sich extrem dadurch entsteht eine menge staub denn der wahlfreiheit stern wind ist der kohlenstoff
Reich der staub selbst ist warm und kann daher gut im infraroten beobachtet werden doch auch das ist eigentlich
Ein merkwürdiges phänomen denn in der nähe eines solchen sterns ist es viel zu heiß und 11 die strahlung würde die staubpartikel
Eigentlich zerstören doch dort wo die sternwinde der beiden sterne aufeinandertreffen da ist es tatsächlich
Kühl genug damit sich staub bilden kann wie das mit den temperaturen rund
Um, sternen sterne sich welt das weiß man ja immer noch nicht
So ganz genau deswegen ist ja jetzt eine sonde unterwegs. Zusammen dass. Sich die beiden sterne selbst umeinander bewegen entsteht letztendlich
Dann, das spiral muster aus staub acht monate braucht das system
Um, sich einmal, um, sich selbst zu drehen und die todesspirale umfasst zudem
Wohl, unglaubliche, 160 astronomische einheiten und das ist wirklich kaum. Zu glauben denn damit ist die knapp doppelt
So groß wie unser sonnensystem. Damit man es sich besser vorstellen kann hier mal vergleich unser sonnensystem bis. Hinaus zum
Neptun hat nur. Einen radius von 30 astronomischen einheiten von freiheit sterne
Sind die hellsten und größten der uns bekannten sterne sie sind sogar 10 bis 2 150 sonnenmassen groß
Zudem haben, sie wie gesagt den. Größten teil der atmosphäre schon
Abgestoßen wenn die sterne sterben entsteht mindestens eine. Supernova explosion eventuell sogar eine deutlich stärkere
Supernova aus den polen des sternschießen. Lang gammastrahlen heraus und genau das könnte
Zu einem großen problem für das leben auf der erde werden denn bei eintritt eines solchen gammablitze auf die erdatmosphäre
Würde sich die ozonschicht. Wohl auflösen. Und das hätte weitreichende konsequenzen für das
Leben auf der erde, denn die
Ozonschicht schützt unsere lebewesen hier auf der erde vor der gefährlichen uv strahlung und dieser schutz wäre dann nicht mehr gegeben
Wir würden quasi hier verbrennen so viel sonnencreme können was ich gar nicht auftragen
Um, sich davor zu schützen immer wieder
mal haben forschungsteams weltweit wer 100 wir deswegen im blick denn eine entfernung von 8000 litern bedeutet im weltall nicht wirklich die welt
Der 2018 hieß es. Dann dass die rotationsachse des doppelsternsystems
Direkt auf unser sonnensystem zeigt und er in den nächsten
100. Jahren explodieren könnte. Ok, entspannung dauert. Noch die große frage aber trotzdem
Könnten uns die gammastrahlenblitze hier auf der erde treffen. Und im schlimmsten fall das leben vernichten astronomie team sind sich mittlerweile
Einig dass. Keine direkte. Gefahr von mehr als 4 ausgeht denn inzwischen sind neue bilder von dem
Jahr, im jahr, 1998 entdeckten doppelsternsystem. Entstanden und diese zeigen dass die erde
Eben nicht exakt auf seine pole zeigt oder dem strahl liegen könnte der dann entsteht wir werden also voraussichtlich
Nicht getroffen trotzdem bieten uns, wahlfreiheit sterne die tolle möglichkeit mehr über große sterne
Zu erfahren die staub spirale von veranda 4 zeigt uns. Wo wir herkommen denn auch unsere erde besteht genau
Wie wir menschen aus kohlenstoff und anderen schweren elementen die vor langer zeit, mal vom. Großen stern erzeugt wurden wenn
Er übrigens alle videos als erste sehen wollt dann abonniert auch den, englischen kanal von
Krieg zum science fiction hier einfach draufklicken da gibt es immer wieder auf - zuerst wie zum beispiel
Food made by some like einfach da drunter drauf klicken und los geht's bis dann
bleibt dran